Okay, ich war gar nicht. Guten Tag. Mein Name ist Hakim Özogbel. Ich bin hier der zuständige Arzt.
Und bevor wir anfangen, muss ich Ihre persönliche Daten notieren und dann sprechen wir über Ihre aktuelle Beschwerden.
Sind Sie dankbar? Ja, natürlich. Klar.
Okay, zuerst, wie heißen Sie? Ich heiße Kurt Bergmann. Ich bin also ein Mann.
Okay, Kurt Bergmann. Könnten Sie bitte Ihren Vorname büsterbieren?
Ja, der Vorname ist Kurt mit K, R, T. Okay.
Und Bergmann mit B, E, R, G. Und dann Mann dahinter.
Und dann Mann. Okay. Wie alt sind Sie? Ich bin 53 Jahre alt.
Okay. Und wann sind Sie genau geboren? Hallo.
Irgendwie. Können Sie mich hören? Jetzt kann ich hören, ja.
Okay. Okay, dann ich mal weiter. Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
15, 3, 68.
Okay. Und wie viel wiegen Sie und wie groß sind Sie, Herr Bergmann?
Ja, ich bin 80 Kilo und bin so 1,75.
Okay. Was sind Sie von Beruf?
Ich arbeite als Tierpfleger im Zoo.
Okay. Sind Sie verheiratet? Ja.
Haben Sie Kinder? Ja, wir haben drei Kinder.
Die freuen sich alle auf Weihnachten.
Ja. Okay. Also, Herr Bergmann, was führt Sie zu uns
und was kann ich für Sie kreieren?
Ja, also ich habe wirklich extreme Schmerzen in meiner rechten Hand,
und zwar so im Handgelenk.
Das muss ich dazu sagen, ich war vorhin mit meinem Motorrad unterwegs
und dann war es wohl doch ein bisschen glatt auf der Straße
und da bin ich weggerutscht und bin gestürzt mit dem Motorrad
und ich hatte zwar gute Schutzkleidung an und ein Helm auf,
aber ich bin wohl auf die rechte Hand gefallen
und das rechte Handgelenk tut mir also sehr weh
und auch die ganze rechte Seite, also da am Brustkorb tut es mir weh
und da habe ich auch ein paar blaue Flecken
und da ist auch ein bisschen die Haut abgeschürft trotz der Schutzkleidung.
Okay.
Ich meine, ich war ganz langsam, da ist also so nicht viel passiert,
aber eben die Hand und der Brustbereich, das tut mir sehr weh.
Okay.
Wann war der Umfeld?
Ja, das ist so zweieinhalb Stunden her.
Ich bin dann erst nach Hause und habe gedacht, ja, war nicht so schlimm,
aber jetzt tut die Hand doch so doll weh
und dass ich das nicht mehr aushalten kann.
Okay.
Haben Sie Luftnot?
Luftnot direkt nicht, aber so beim Einatmen tut es einfach weh.
Da werden die Schmerzen schlimmer.
Okay.
Und gibt es auf eine Wunde in Ihrer rechten Hand
oder noch ein bisschen abschiffen?
An der Hand ist eigentlich nichts,
so ein bisschen Hautabschiffung am Körper, an der Seite.
Okay.
Und können Sie Ihre rechte Hand bewegen?
Nein, das geht überhaupt nicht mehr.
Ich kann die gar nicht mehr bewegen
und die ist auch ordentlich angeschwollen
und eben sehr schmerzhaft.
Und streiten die Schmerzen irgendwohin aus?
Die Schmerzen in der rechten Hand?
Na, ich würde sagen, die sind nur da lokal im Handgelenk.
Ich glaube nicht, ausstrahlen tun sie nicht.
Wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf einer Spalle von 1 bis 10,
wobei 1 sehr leicht und 10 sehr stark Schmerzen entspricht?
Oh, die sind schon bei 7 bis 8, die sind wirklich heftig, die Schmerzen, ja.
Okay.
Und haben Sie auch bemerkt, dass Sie Ihr Kopf geschlagen haben?
Ihr Kopf?
Nein, also am Kopf spüre ich nichts.
Ich habe auch so ein Hals keine Beschwerden.
Ich habe den Helm auf und ich glaube, ich habe mehr mit der Körperseite abgefangen.
Ich bin nicht auf den Kopf gefallen.
Okay.
Haben Sie noch andere Beschwerden?
Nein, aber das reicht auch für mich.
Das ist sehr unangenehm.
Okay, aber es ist ja schon gut, dass Sie zu uns gekommen sind
und wir werden unsere Bestes geben, um jede Schmerz zu gehen.
Ja, das ist ja gut.
Okay, jetzt möchte ich ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer Krankengeschichte stellen.
Spenden Sie an irgendwas vor Erkrankungen, wie zum Beispiel Blutdruck oder Spalkrankheit?
Ja, ich habe eher niedrigen Blutdruck.
Eigentlich schon lange, das ist eigentlich ziemlich ungewöhnlich.
Alle anderen Leute haben hohen, ich habe niedrigen Blutdruck.
Und ja, seit fünf Jahren habe ich einen Bandscheibenvorfall in der Halswirbelsäule.
Ich bin da eigentlich ein bisschen eingeschränkt.
Und sind Sie schon mal operiert worden?
Ja, vor 25 Jahren hatte ich mal eine Achilleszenenrist.
Das ist operativ versorgt worden.
Und vor fünf Jahren bin ich sterilisiert worden.
Vor 25 Jahren, was hatten Sie genau? Ich konnte nicht akustisch verstehen.
Da ist die Achilleszenen gerissen und das wurde operativ versorgt.
Okay, und vor fünf Jahren?
Bitte?
Vor fünf Jahren?
Das war Stereolisation.
Okay, leben Ihre Eltern noch?
Nein, mein Vater lebt nicht mehr.
Der ist vor zehn Jahren verstorben.
Der hat den Herzinfarkt.
Und meine Mutter lebt aber noch.
Wie alt ist sie?
Wie alt ist sie denn? Das muss ich eben schnell rechnen.
Schnell, schwierige Frage.
Sie ist 80.
Leidet sie an irgendwelche Vorerkrankungen?
Ja, die hat jetzt kürzlich eine kleine Hautopie gehabt,
weil sie an der Schlefe einen weißen Hautkrebs hat.
Aber jetzt im hohen Alter ist das, glaube ich, nicht so relevant.
Okay.
Haben Sie eine Schwester?
Eine Schwester habe ich ja.
Ist sie gesund?
Ja, nicht wirklich.
Sie haben Magersucht, aber so gut, chronische Krankheiten,
so was hat sie sonst nicht mehr.
Okay.
Sind jeder Kinder gesund?
Die Kinder sind alle fit, ja.
Okay.
Haben Sie Fieber oder haben Sie Fieber gehabt?
Nein.
Haben Sie Schlafprobleme?
Normalerweise nicht.
Okay.
Ist die Appetit gut?
Ja, eigentlich schon.
Haben Sie Probleme mit dem Stuhlgang oder bei Wasserlassen?
Wasserlassen habe ich keine Probleme, ich habe häufiger mal Durchfall.
Aber ich nehme da keine Medikamente.
Ich esse dann nur ein bisschen vorsichtiger.
Herr Bergmann, fühlen Sie sich gestresst oder nicht gestrigen?
Jetzt im Augenblick fühle ich mich schon gestresst,
weil mein Motorrad kaputt ist und meine Hand knifft.
Aber ich bin mit meinem Job sehr zufrieden.
Und in meiner Lebenssituation.
Ja, verstehe.
Nehmen Sie illegal Medikamente?
Ja, ich habe irgendwelche Tropfen, die den Blutbruch nach oben bringen.
Ich weiß aber nicht, wie die heißen.
Wenn ich mal Schmerzen habe, so in der Schulter oder von der Bandscheibe her,
dann nehme ich Ibuprofen.
Und dann habe ich noch regelmäßig eine Cortison-Salbe,
weil ich so ein bisschen Neurodermitis habe.
Jetzt so außen an den Oberarmen.
Aber mit der Salbe komme ich da ganz gut zurecht.
Okay.
Neurodermatitis, seit wann haben Sie?
Ach, das habe ich schon als Kind gehabt.
Ah, Kind?
Ja, jetzt ist es halt an den Oberarmen überwiegend.
Aber mit der Salbe habe ich das gut im Gericht.
Okay.
Und welche Seite? Welche Oberarmen?
Beide, auf beiden Seiten.
Okay.
Heilbergmann, werfen Sie?
Ja, zwar nicht mehr so doll.
Früher habe ich mal 20 Jahre lang 20 Zigaretten am Tag.
Also ein Päckchen am Tag geraucht.
Jetzt habe ich das sehr reduziert.
Seit vier Jahren rauche ich nur noch ganz wenig,
noch so 50er-Raten am Tag.
Seit vier.
Ein Päckchen hält vier Tage, das ist gut.
Trinkt man sie Alkohol?
Alkohol, naja, also ich trink ein Bier am Tag, ja.
Und wenn mal irgendwo etwas zu feiern ist,
dann trinkt man auch wohl mal ein bisschen mehr,
aber also nicht viel.
Okay.
Nehmen Sie sonst getragen?
Nein.
Okay.
Sind bei Ihnen irgendwelche Allergien
oder Unfalltäglichkeiten weg?
Ja, tatsächlich habe ich eine Kontrastmittelallergie.
Also beim Röntgen darf ich kein Kontrastmittel kriegen.
Okay.
Wie reagieren Sie darauf?
Ja, so mit Hitze und dass das Gesicht rot wird
und die Haut kribbelt und so.
Okay, Herr Bergmann, ich bin fast fertig,
aber ich habe vergessen, ich frage, ist Ihnen schwindelt?
Ich finde nicht.
Nein, ich finde, ist mir nicht.
Nein.
Und Sie haben ja gesagt, Sie haben normalerweise
niedriger Blutdruck gedrückt.
Genau.
Okay.
Und haben Sie schon mal Ihre Bewusstsein verloren?
Nein, eigentlich nicht.
Okay.
Und bei der Unfall auch nicht?
Nein, nein, nein, ich war die ganze Zeit dabei.
Okay.
Jetzt bin ich mit den Fragen fertig, Herr Bergmann.
Möchten Sie es?
Ja, ich habe das.
Ich möchte natürlich fragen, was Sie jetzt mit mir machen
und ja, was wir gegen die Schmerzen tun können,
weil das wirklich, also gerade die Hand tut mir sehr weh.
Und natürlich bin ich auch in Sorge.
Ich werde ja die nächste Zeit mit der Hand nicht arbeiten können.
Wenn das weiter so wehtut.
Was da war, war das.
Ich habe das.
Wenn ich die Hand nicht arbeiten können.
Wenn das weiter so wehtut.
Was da wohl, ja, was mit der Hand los ist, ne.
Ja.
Okay.
Ja, okay.
Ich fange ganz gut.
Eigentlich ist es zu viel, etwas Konkretes zu sagen.
Ich werde Sie zuerst körperlich untersuchen.
Und dann.
Ich werde Ihnen Blut ab.
Ich werde Ihnen Blut ab und dann ich anordne für Sie eine Röntgenaufnahme von rechten Hand und von Brustkorb.
Ah, ja, okay.
Damit wir beurteilen können, ob es einen Bruch oder was gibt.
Ja, und dann können wir genauer besprechen.
Ja, das ist gut.
Okay, ja, jetzt können Sie im Marktzimmer Platz nehmen und dann, wie ich wieder vielleicht...
Es dauert aber nicht lange, ne?
Ja, nicht lange. Und ich ordne schnell einen Schmerz mit der Prüde sehen.
Oh, das ist gut, ja.
Gut, ich sitze jetzt im Wartezimmer. Hat irgendjemand von den Kollegen noch Fragen?
Alle sind völlig erschöpft, keiner hat eine Frage.
Haben Sie erbrochen?
Oh, gute Frage. Nee, habe ich nicht.
Okay.
Vielleicht braucht Schmerzen Fragen.
Ah, ja, genau. Das steht vielleicht auch noch interessant.
Haben Sie Beuseinverloden?
Nee, habe ich nicht. Hat er aber auch gefragt, meine ich.
Ja, hat er gefragt.
Ja.
Ich habe es nicht verloren.
Genau, ich habe gesagt, ich war die ganze Zeit dabei.
Genau, weiß ich noch. Ja, okay.
Gut, soll er weiter machen, oder?
Nee, da ist auch jemand, der etwas fragen will.
Sie sind in der CDU geimpft.
Ah, das ist eine gute Frage. Ja, Tetanusimpfung.
Ja, genau, Impfstatus hat er gar nicht gefragt.
Ja, ja, ja, also ich bin gegen Tetanus geimpft.
Ja, und auch gegen Corona.
Gut, okay, dann weiter machen.
Okay, einen Moment.
Hallo, Frau Obersten.
Ich möchte Ihnen einen neuen Patientin,
den ich gerade aufgenommen habe vorstellen.
Ja, sehr gut, okay.
Der ist das sein, der.
Die Zeit dafür? Ja, ja, klar.
Okay.
Herr Bergmann ist ein 53-jähriger Patient.
Er kam zu uns heute
wegen
Schmerzen im rechten Handgelenk
und rechte Seite von seinem Brustkorb.
Nach dem einen Motorradon.
Nach dem Brustkorb.
Okay, Moment.
Er kam zu uns wegen
Schmerzen in Artikulation Manus, Dextra
und rechte Seite von Thorac Schmerzen.
Ja, nach einem Motorradonfall.
Er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist ein
Er ist weggerutscht nach der rechten Seite und gestürzt.
Er sagt, der Unfall war vor 2,5 Stunden.
Er ist zuerst nach Hause gegangen, aber dann sind die Schmerzen schlimmer geworden.
Er hat auch Hematom im rechten Antepracium und rechten Seite Torax Regionen.
Er hat kein Dispner, aber bei der Inspiration sind die Schmerzen schlimmer geworden.
Er bewertet die Schmerzintensität auf der Schmerzschkala von 1 bis 10.
Im Torax soll die Schmerzen in der Hand?
Er kann seine Hand nicht bewegen wegen Schmerzen.
Die Fragen nach Nausea und Weitigo wurden verneint.
Er hat die Schmerzen in der Hand verneint.
Er hat die Neurodermitis beiseitig erkannter.
Er behandelt die mit Cortison Salve?
Er hat vor 25 Jahren Arschillesternoliter.
Vor 5 Jahren hat er Sterilisation.
Er ist 18 Jahre alt.
Er hat eine Hautoperation wegen Basalium in der Region Temporals.
Er wohnt in Altenheim.
Er hat eine Schwester, aber keine andere.
Er hat kein Fieber.
Er ist unaufhörlich.
Er ist psychisch unaufhörlich.
Er hat eine Medikamente.
Er ist nicht erinnerlich.
Er ist nicht hypertonisch.
Er gibt einen ehemaligen Konsum von 20 Jahren.
Seit 4 Jahren braucht er 50 Räder täglich.
Er gibt einen Alkoholkonsum von 1,5 Tage.
Er hat einen Konsum von 1,5 Tage.
Er hat 2 Diagnosen.
Ich habe viele Fehler gemacht.